un bruit de diesel et un décor de cinéma
avec ce contournant unique en france
nous sommes au lac de briller en indre
et loire depuis 40 ans des passionnés
sont des machines et un patrimoine
exceptionnel
cette pièce c'est quand même curieux et
moi j ai l'un des deux fondateurs
aujourd'hui l'enjeu est de transmettre
ce savoir faire ça fait partie de nos
objectifs la formation des jeunes et des
moins jeunes aux techniques spécifiques
vapeur est également savoir faire
fonctionner le train parce qu'on ne fait
pas fonctionnaire un train même à voie
étroite tout à fait comme on veut il ya
des consignes à des règles bernard fait
partie de ces passionnés
il a beau habiter près de toulon à 900
km d'ici depuis son stage vapeur en 2006
il revient chaque année
bon voilà je suis là depuis le 28
juillet donc une quinzaine de jours des
fois il ya des chantiers l'hiver donc je
reste une semaine mais je peux pas venir
pour être au courant des chantiers de
voix je viens une semaine une semaine ni
généralement c'est au moins de novembre
quand il ya des ponts donc ça s'arrange
toujours dans la rotonde
on retrouve un autre passionné julien
qui vient ici depuis ses 9 ans
il vient de finir la restauration de 7,2
coville mue par un moteur baudouin on
est formé par les différents anciens de
l'association la restauration à la
soudure la tôlerie toutes ces choses là
ça m'a permis de restaurer entre deux et
trois engins et
on ferait à mesure des années on
progresse on apprend etc
on va manoeuvrer thomas tu pourra
manipuler le ponton ans même si ces
jeunes n'ont pas connu l'époque des
trains à vapeur
il reste fasciné par ces machines un
jour ce sont ceux qui reprendront le
flambeau